Kim Kardashian strips down to nearly
nothing I'm so curvy that if I try to
like put other things on and I look like
a joke the 37 year old Keeping Up with
the Kardashians star bares it all for
her latest magazine cover posing for the
20th anniversary of Richardson here's
Kim Kate wearing only a small pair of
underwear with her legs spread for an
anime inspired editorial she kept her
makeup simple and appeared to sports
share life hair draping down her back
there's definitely those moments when
you're like what was I thinking what was
I wearing inside the reality star was
featured completely naked on her hands
and knees in a bathtub covering her face
and showing off all her curves this
isn't the first racy photo shoot of the
week Kim shared topless snaps of herself
in bed to promote her latest k'kaw
beauty makeup line the flashing lights
collection seemingly inspired by her
husband Kanye West
[Music]
well it's no secret that Kim is
comfortable in her own skin but she's
also no stranger to body shaming and you
cheek pictures and if they're not like
perfect people just like Bobby shame you
and criticize you earlier this year she
came under fire after her sisters
praised her dramatic slimmed down after
Kim shared her new weight 119 pounds
Thank You amazing
after receiving backlash about how she
and her family talked about body image
Kim apologized to her fans on Ashley
Graham's pretty big deal podcast quote
my intention is never to offend anyone
and I really apologize if I offended
anyone really just opened up a whole
different perspective for me
Kim has also changed her outlook on sex
after welcoming three kids telling
Richardson quote my public persona is
wild sexual but I'm actually
uncomfortable when I talk about sex and
I'm more conservative when it comes to
that adding I can go on set and be fully
naked in front of 50 people doing a
shoot but if I'm one-on-one intimate in
bed I'm like shy and insecure
I think motherhood has actually made me
more confident about being publicly sexy
[Music]